so new york city officials declare
monkey pox a public health emergency
this is an msn story new york city
officials declare monkey pox a public
emergency on saturday in an effort to
respond more efficiency efficiently to
the current outbreak which may begin in
may which began in may san francisco was
the first u.s city to declare a state of
emergency to combat the monkey pox
outbreak last week in a joint statement
new york city mayor eric adams and dr
ashwin vassan commissioner of the city
health and mental hygiene department
said that new york is currently the
epicenter of the monkey pox outbreak in
the u.s and the estimate that about
approximately 150 000 new yorkers may
currently be at risk of them by only 50
or 800 cases what are they talking about
yeah both officials also said that the
outbreak must be met with urgency action
and resources both nationally and
globally and that the declaration
reflected the seriousness of the moment
as of august 1st the new york city
health department has reported
1472 cases of monkey pox i heard a
couple of things uh this morning when i
was listening to the news uh first of
all they only have 300 and i think 50 uh
vaccines available for it it doesn't
kill you and it's only really really
rampant in the gay community which i
don't even know how like
it just popped out of north the guy was
like it's not like an age it's not gonna
kill anybody so it's not like it
shouldn't be like oh my god but they
have they have limited amount of
vaccines for this even though we do have
sun and there's only one small is it
dutch i may get that wrong one small
dutch comp company that's actually uh
that makes it happen
the chat can correct me or tyler you can
look that up but i think there's only
one small dutch company that's making
the vaccine oh really
i gotta tell you we're gonna invest in
that on them tom let's get on that i
don't i don't call it like
covet fatigue whatever
like
i'm hearing about just like i don't got
no ain't nobody got no time for your
monkey pops
i ain't got going to the [ __ ] zoo
i don't gotta i'm not dealing with
smallpox monkeybox
i'm not dealing with tupac
none of it i'm dealing with i'm done i
like i see the monkey pucks pop up i'm
like all right keep it moving i'm gonna
i'm not gonna front though i did see
some videos about where the guy some guy
was like on a world star and he was talk
bro it looks
really really bad i wouldn't want it i'm
sure but he was just like yeah man i
just you know i was at a uh it was a
weird story he's like i was at a i don't
i'm not trying to be funny yeah there's
not like a
sexual orgy type situation goes you know
i was making out with a bunch of guys
and i got it and then he goes like eight
other guys in the plays god and i was a
guy all of all guys
can you can you pull up the article yeah
i was gonna show you this these are the
vaccine requirements in new york city
you can only be vaccinated if you meet
the following conditions gay bisexual or
other man who has sex with men 18 or
older have had multiple or uh anonymous
sex partners in the last 14 days um you
should consider getting vaccinated if
you met partners through online
applications such as grind or tinder or
have a condition that may increase your
risk for severe death if infected with
monkey pox such as hiv is there a phone
number for this why is this a public
emergency like maybe in new york i get
it but you're going to see i think
you're just looking again pull up that
article please i just said that this is
not someone i'm paying attention to but
this seems to be running rampant in the
gay community is that what's going on
yeah specifically men yeah which is kind
of i don't even know what it comes out
of here guys here's a cm when's the last
time you would you would expect c and no
show the logo at the top left so they
know who are this is a cnbc story
world health organization recommends gay
and bisexual men limit sexual partners
to reduce the spread of monkey pox
zoom in a little bit to read some of
this
zoom in a little bit to read some of
this men who have sex with men are the
highest risk of infection right now from
monkey pox about 99 of cases are among
men and at least 95 of those patients
are men who are having sex with other
men according to
world health organization tedros
said men who have sex with men should
consider limiting their sexual partners
to lower their risk of infection reduce
their spread the world health
organization chief called on media
public health authorities and government
to fight stigma and discrimination which
you said will only fuel the outbreak
well there goes my weekend
it just came out of nowhere how about
but notice how they were trying to make
it like it was another pandemic no it's
not bro it's only targeting a small
group can you scroll back did it say 99
of cases or with
men hooking up with men scrolling
yeah i mean i'm not even being sarcastic
i'm not like if you're a gay man slow
down and this is what you're dealing and
this is you should be concerned 100 and
i i implore you to act accordingly yeah
okay nobody wants anybody to get sick
nobody wants to get these diseases
um you're at risk yep for the for the
other you know
rest of us
carry out so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]